Oh
[Music]
we know that users were front-facing our
20% more likely to be swiped right on
relative to individuals who are side
facing and those individuals who smile
with their mouths open are 14% more
likely to be right swiped on relative to
individuals who are not smiling so I
strongly encourage individuals to use a
super like when they're very interested
in somebody and we know that when
individuals are more likely to super
like somebody that there are three times
more likely to match with them and have
a longer conversation after
[Music]
so by sending a reengagement text or
gift for example it can be super helpful
to you to try to keep the conversation
going and pretty effective and we know
that individuals who send gifts are 30%
more likely to get a response
one of the most important things when
evaluating an individual and their face
isn't just whether or not they're
attractive but also other qualities
about somebody and we know that by
wearing glasses you reduce your
likelihood of being swiped right on by
15% and by wearing a hat you reduce your
likelihood of being swiped on by 12% so
I would highly recommend to individuals
to skip the glasses and skip the hats in
your primary profile photo as well as
your additional photos
[Music]
you
[Music]